is the multi-hyphenate
nate burleson back here on the show how
are you nate
i'm good how are you doing i've been i'm
great i i wanted to have you on uh it's
my first show back in a month and um
i texted you when i read the news and i
just wanted to say here on the show i
couldn't be more excited for you this is
amazing this developer yeah i appreciate
that that text um like i told you
in our messages um i appreciate you as a
friend but more importantly as a
colleague and a mentor you know the the
times
um that we've worked together and being
able to
basically watch you from a distance and
take some of the things that you do so
well try to add them to to my toolbox
it's it's really put me in a position
where
um as of right now i've
i've kind of
transcended the
football
analyst role and um and i'm thankful for
the people that i was able to work with
in my earlier days national network
which obviously includes you well i mean
you're so kind to say that all i know is
that gail king is going to have no
problem uh having a colleague tell her
that she's mixed up winston and watson
uh in real time
as you did a couple of decembers ago in
tampa during a commercial break you're
like hey
but i mean this is so um amazing nate
because again um you know stray as we
all know going from the world of the nfl
to good morning america and now you
going from the world of the nfl to cbs
this morning this means so much i think
for nfl players
um
for sure just and certainly for people
who think you know maybe they don't have
a shot maybe they don't know if they
have the chops but they don't know until
they try and succeed at it i think this
is so inspiring nate and i i don't mind
telling you that for real yeah no i i
i'm i'm thankful for individuals like
you that are willing to voice that um
it's
it's a very unique situation because
there is
there's still an immense amount of
pressure on me as an individual to
prove that not only can i be a
media personality
but also have the
journalistic chops to
really swim with you know some of the
the best journalists in the world and um
i
i originally went into tv because
i'm a creative by nature and as much as
i love football
it was just a small part of who i was
and i've always felt like
i just need people to to see me and and
not see me in a uniform not see me with
a helmet on
not even seeing me as an alice talking
about the sport but just see me you know
i fell in love with poetry at a young
age i am into movies pop culture of
music
and i knew that eventually i would dive
back into a space of comfort which is
i'm talking about not just sports but
also news
and right now
this is a
a very
um
a very
you know
unique time for
athletes because we
we um
we we've had individuals before me
i've said this on air before ahmad
rashad was
the biggest influence i ever had in my
life he was a football player
transitioning to
basketball
and for the first time i've seen a cool
black man that was
that was so comfortable in his own skin
and this was um me as a youngster now i
know individuals came before him and
came after him but i'm talking about my
immediate influence of seeing somebody
that looked like me on tv was a moderate
shot and so many years later i'm
following that path so
um i know that the seat on cbs this
morning is
a very privileged position it's it's
it's a prized piece of real estate
and there's a legacy of individuals that
came before me men and women that i am
going to honor and uphold
so it's um
it's it's a great time a great time to
to really open up the door even further
for athletes who
understand and appreciate being an nfl
player but more importantly know that
like your next chapter could be your
best best chapter i love it nate
burleson here uh on the rich eisen show
so just quick nuts and bolts on it when
when do you start when do we see you on
that set when does that go uh i believe
september 7th okay this is my
my first
day and then um from there i'll still be
involved in it and the nfl media family
and the great nfl network i'm still
doing uh some stuff on
um you know certain kent poll events
that the nfl network has i'm gonna be
joining you certain
sundays oh fantastic with you on your
show so yes you know i i was i was able
to
you know find a balance between
you know leaving good morning football
and still being part of the nfl network
family as you know
which i i don't think a lot of people
know um you know my first appearance on
the info network was back in 03 and i
used to come back every single summer
there were times where i worked shows
there were times where i worked the nfl
am show times where i did total access
and there was times where i just flew
myself into california just so i can
watch what you guys are doing and just
sit back behind the scene
so this is a long time coming almost 20
years of a relationship that i've
established with the nfl network just so
i could
be in this position now you know
here's what i love about you rich
you have put in work
and as much as people can appreciate
your
you're working in radio and tv uh
and
and what you mean to both
sports and football
i don't think people really understand
the work that they don't see you know
similar to an athlete so
i'm i'm also one of those guys that
i'll
sweat and bleed and put in work behind
the scenes
and then um kind of reap the rewards
afterwards well i mean nate you just
don't get and i appreciate you saying
what you said nate burleson here on the
rich housing show you don't get as you
point a prize piece of real estate a
chair on the set of cbs this morning and
cbs news um and
and and without obviously them
assessing your work uh uh on cbs sports
and also with nfl network and finding
out about the your work ethic and how
hard it is it is so difficult i mean the
number of times that i've had
um i've had you know um
auditions uh with players that just come
off the field and they feel like oh well
i know football just talk about it it's
so not that it's so difficult and then
of course to be as natural as you are
and showing off who you are as a person
and what what what you're made of i mean
i couldn't be more excited and i i can't
wait to see what you do in the news
world as well it's going to be something
to see and i think it's terrific that
cbs saw your abilities to and give you
that shot man i i'm very excited for
that that's a fact thank you that that
means a lot i um not i've been working
for uh extra the last couple of years
and um in full transparency you know as
much as i appreciate the
experience working with extra and
them
paying me a decent amount not a
mind-blowing amount but just paying me
to
work the field do red carpets and talk
to celebrities it was it was me
really strategizing and and proving that
i can work in that space and talk to um
influencers and
and actresses and you know some of the
top actors in the world and i i remember
a few opportunities that i had to talk
to
j.lo and michelle obama and i remember
doing the red carpet for the irishman
and as i'm sitting here with a
microphone i'm jostling for a position
and literally elbowing other journalists
and i'm like this isn't this isn't what
i should be doing but i feel like it's
good for me right now at this point in
my career and i'm i'm reaching my
microphone now and i i talked to de niro
and and and then pacino walks by and i'm
i'm like hey uh how hey what's up can i
can i get you for a second and you know
as i go to introduce myself hey listen
i'm making burleson i'm a huge fan and
he cuts me off he's like i i know who
you are
yeah you're the football guy yeah yeah i
i watch you you do the morning show you
do sundays he's like yeah i love
football
and in that moment
um i might i started sweating
i looked at the camera hey i was
literally sweating behind my knees and i
looked at the camera and i i i tried to
motion to my producer who was on the
field with me in the red carpet i said
they cut the cameras off for a second i
said
mr patino do you know who i am he's like
yeah yeah yeah i do i do and i'm like
i'm i'm blown away right now he's like
you're doing good work yeah i see you
and i um
that meant a lot to me not because i was
meeting one of my favorite actors but it
was it was somebody that was so far
removed from the traditional
sports space and he was just saying i've
seen you i've seen you put in work since
you left
the nfl and uh
and that that's that's all i've been
trying to do you know there's
listen rich man there's
there's people that look at uh nate
burleson being hired by cbs this morning
and they're saying what are you guys
doing you know anthony mason was a
tremendous tremendous man a medal and
he's extremely talented rich history
you know
someone you know one of the individuals
that
you you you can't replace
i understand
the the hesitation i understand the
trepidation of fans that are saying well
well what are we doing here are you guys
trying to
like are you guys trying to do the
straight hand thing with nate burleson
i love strand one of my mentors um
i'm just gonna do my path differently
and
as much as i can say this
um and this isn't me patting myself on
the back
what i can say is
i was meant for this job
and what i've done over the last
seven years
have been training so i don't let people
down when this opportunity
um presents itself so
these are
these are the
the moments before my next chapter
uh opens up and
for anybody that has been paying
attention to my career
just know that
nothing nothing has been done
accidentally everything that i've done
up to this point
working at the nfl network doing digital
content pre-game post game watching host
when they're like when i would work with
you
i would look at you
i would watch your lips in your body
language as you read the teleprompter
and i would try to mimic that i did the
same thing with james brown i did it
with dad heli lindsey rose the list goes
on and on and on and um
i did that because
i wanted to work and be better than
i was and i i didn't want anybody to box
me in of course i can tell you about a
post corner for the next 20 years i can
break down football x's and those with
my eyes closed i can do that but
um i i wasn't
i wasn't put on this earth to do that i
was put on this earth to be informative
and entertaining and right now i'm
landing in a position that is a
privileged privileged position
that um is going to be
it's going to be quite a ride so i i
appreciate you
you always being there for me and
dropping the gems you know and always
being a shoulder i can lean on
and i'm gonna make the football world
proud and and i i hope years from now
five years ten years
twenty years from now athletes can walk
away from the game and know that
it isn't the end of some glorious
lifestyle some rock star lifestyle it is
the beginning of your life
because that's that's exactly what it
was in 14 when i retired
there was this moment where i was like
godly man i
i'm not a rock star anymore you know i
play with randy and calvin i can walk
into any restaurant and they would cover
my bill and high-five me and fans would
come up and say say hey nate thank you
for helping me win my fantasy team and
0-4 i love that
ego driven diva receiver i loved it
and then
about five years into my retirement when
people walked up to me
and they didn't mention football and
they were talking about
how they appreciated the work i put in
in the media space
that was more fulfilling than anybody
telling me how great i was at running
and jumping and catching footballs so
um
i'm trying to just
to widen the spectrum of what we see
athletes are well and and and you're
you're nailing that and obviously you
know the one thing i take from that
whole story is that you beat mario lopez
in man coverage to get to al pacino well
done so you're using all you're using
all of your
um you're using all of your skill sets
but i i i love every last word that you
just said and you're going to kill it
you really are going to crush it nate
and and i i fully believe that and look
uh i have you know
i guess the only thing i could equate
what you just said to
when i i got to sportscenter at age 26
right they didn't know who the hell i
was everybody oh young
yeah i was 26 years old when i got to
the first set of sportscenter that that
was that was a that was like brown hair
rich that was oh yeah oh yeah there's
remember robot thursday brown hair flock
of seagulls big old haircut yes
the whole thing and um and i went on the
air and a whole bunch of people were
like who the hell was this guy like you
know because that was the world of of
keith olbermann and dan and yeah and
robin roberts and bob lee and charlie
steiner were doing the the early sports
center and here i come 26 and uh with my
stand-up comedy background and i just
made everything a joke and i've heard a
lot about you know why is he here why
you know this is something that i i'm a
fan of
um i got that stuart scott my god did he
get that just like you know what what
the hell is he doing here
why why is he bringing his style and his
sensibilities that that don't make sense
to me
uh at all and and he just kept pressing
on i kept pressing on
if you hear anything about that what
you're doing is not a fit for some
viewer or whatever just keep doing it
put a new fresh coat of paint on the
next day keep doing it keep doing it and
suddenly you know you're you've been
there a while and everyone's uh
respecting what you're doing that would
be my only two cents based on that
and you know this is maybe a
conversation we could have sure um you
know author offline and through text but
i like the fact that we can have a
normal conversation the viewers can you
know be he flies on the wall uh when you
decide to make that move from
sportscenter yeah
network yeah which was a big move
um
even even me young 21 year old nate
burleson at the time hearing about it it
was
it was monumental you know and a lot of
people questioned it
you know they're thinking like what in
the world why in the hell would this guy
leave this hallmark network to
let's call it what it is some sports nfl
based startup
like what was
what was the reason behind that and how
did you how did you put on the blinders
and not get distracted by
you know all of the
doubters that might have been you know
putting obstacles or hurdles in your way
well it was kind of a mix one uh
management at espn made it uh untenable
for me to stay um and two um i i was
firmly believing that what i was doing
as much as i loved it that there was
more for me to do
and the people that were in in position
there to make me to allow me to do i i
wanted actually to do some of the stuff
that you're doing right now because i
thought you know i had a certain skill
set that maybe morning television
certainly on network tv just doing a
couple of hits here and there for good
morning america but that was not uh in
the cards they didn't
want me to do it allow me to do it
didn't want sportscenter anchors to do
it put me in a little bit of a box and
then you know i had the opportunity uh
in front of me with nfl network along
with another opportunity to call braves
games actually
for tbs and uh what i wound up doing was
going to los angeles
working for somebody who i knew in steve
bornstein because he started nfl network
as well as the president of espn i keep
telling him he's smart enough to have
hired me twice which is why he's in
broadcasting halls of fame
um but in all in all honesty i just
believed this is what i want to do
and i think your circumstances are
obviously a little different because you
were you're on a hit television show in
good morning football having been there
from you know jump pretty much with the
network from your career
and you know obviously you have the
ability to to to keep your feet in other
parts of the broadcasting industry with
cbs and nfl network it's it's a
no-brainer it really is a no-brainer you
will be missed on good morning football
no question about that but you're not
disappearing from the scene
you do you nate you do you man i'm
that's that's that's i don't know if
that answered your question or not but
that's that's what it does and and
that's what you did and that
there's so many individuals uh men and
women and not just in the
sports space but just the media in
general that decided to do them
and took a leap of faith
and also
they they invested
in themselves and i i remember you doing
that
and wow i mean look look where we are
this is 2021 and rich eisen
is an international name
and it's not it's not just it's not just
in football but i mean to have your own
show like
i've been i've been admiring your moves
for a minute so um seeing individuals
like that
you know take take control of their
careers and occasionally occasionally
you have to
you have to like blindfold yourself and
just
and just walk with faith
and it works out and and that's why
there's a deep appreciation and
admiration for for you and the position
you're in well right back at you nate
you know i was going to ask you some
football questions but screw it yeah do
it let's do it am i running out of time
no i i can give you one if you don't
mind you know do it like man come on i'm
not going in the world there you go this
whole day is about you
know actually on vacation this week
all right
here's i'm talking to rich so here you
go here's the one here's the one um what
are receivers in locker rooms that um
have quarterback competitions going on
what are they thinking how do they get
through what's going on maybe in san
francisco new england chicago
um do they deep down
uh have a preference or do they just say
i can't control it i'm just gonna go on
and do my own thing how how does that
work
i think a new generation of wide
receivers
are leaning more towards the more
athletic wide receiver this isn't a shot
to
you know jimmy garoppolo with trey lance
behind them
or andy dalton with justin fields behind
him i i just feel like if i'm a wide
receiver and i'm running a crow row you
know i get off the line of scrimmage i
hit my db with a sweet release move
i come out of my break i got two yards
of separation i'm looking for that rock
quarterback can't see me because the
defensive line has uh fleshed him out of
the pocket
that's where my preference come in
because as as i am looking for him he's
looking for me and he has to go into
scramble mode i get to run two routes in
one play there's no db in the world i
don't care how good you are there's no
db in the world that can stop two routes
and one player average player is around
five to six seconds
if if i get to uh run a secondary route
you're as good as cooked um which is why
we see so many big plays in the kansas
city trees and even
as slow as tom brady is he will still
negotiate that pocket and he will get
outside and extend the play just a
little bit to give chris godwin and mike
evans rob gronkowski just just a little
bit of time to run a secondary route so
i i feel like if i'm a receiver for the
chicago bears i would love to have
justin fields if i'm a receiver for the
sandwich school 49ers i would love to
have trey lance i want that individual
that can like extend the play and give
me a chance to get open twice just think
about that concept for a second as a
receiver i get to get open twice you are
a high paid db getting paid million
dollars plus to stop receivers like me
i have a cheat code with my quarterback
um which is why we we have
we we love to watch
the qb's that extend plays in the way
that they do aaron rodgers who doesn't
get enough credit for his athleticism
he can extend plays with the best of
them when you're watching these guys
practice scramble drills a long time ago
20 years ago 30 years ago used to be
something that rarely happened something
you rarely practice now scrambled
scramble drills are literally part of
the play all right so we're gonna run a
simple concept we'll go uh curl flat
curl flat and then if i actually in the
pocket uh whoever's deep come short meet
me on the sideline if you're short go
deep i'm gonna throw it to the pylon and
if you're a tight end in the middle of
the field i need you to just find a
window that's that's a strategy so it
isn't an accident when big plays happen
it's more of something that is planned
so yeah as a wide receiver not only am i
excited about the more athletic qb's but
i'm making friends with him hey hey hey
trey lance uh what's up man you play
video games but you want a playstation
xbox you wanna you wanna go to toys r us
i know you're young you wanna what do
you want new pair of shoes so yeah
oh no
that's twice in one show he's like
what's happening and now you got to call
him back i mean we know it's not goodbye
yeah so
he was in the middle of something he was
in the middle of something now we gotta
gotta get closure yeah obviously
now this is obvious this is clear yeah
yeah this thing can call him back
that sounds like you know what sounds
like he might have adjusted his ear and
you might have gone off he's
yeah and guess what happened i called
the person of course she did
it all right you there nate i i lost you
i'm not talking for a quick second no
it's all right you're talking about
getting treyland shoes so i get it
no listen man i i sat down with justin
fields uh about two months ago we did
this um
this campaign for progressive insurance
and
um he's he's somebody that understands
the position he's in he wants to work
and prove that he can be an nfl
quarterback but more importantly though
like you know young rookies are
impressionable so if i know i'm joking
around saying i'll buy a you know a
playstation or xbox with these guys with
the money they're making they don't need
anything from work wide receivers but if
i'm a whiteout that's playing for the
49ers or the bears um you know
even the patriots with cam newton and
mac jones
i'm gonna i'm gonna make it
make it a point to reach out to these
guys and say hey let's go grab dinner
like you know let's let's go kick it you
know let's go have a scrap of beer and
talk about football on life so when when
these quarter quarterback competitions
shake themselves out like they'll
they'll be a little more partial to
throwing me to rock it goes a long
friendships go a long way
with qbs and and and wide receivers like
the relationships off the field go a
long way
nate have a great vacation look forward
to seeing you in the mornings on cbs and
uh look for my call throughout the
season and i look forward to continuing
to working with you too means a lot
thanks for the call hey i appreciate you
man thank you so much that's nate
burleson everybody emmy award winner and
now about to dominate
about to dominate a whole new endeavor
love that guy
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here